[Applause]
for nearly 20 years roman abramovich has
showered chelsea with money and been
repaid in silverware but now the
ultimate trophy asset is for sale a
scrutiny of the source of his vast
wealth and the threat of government
sanctions against a one-time ally of
vladimir putin grow their football
club's become very successful and
admired under his
ownership but obviously in the end
those alleged links with vladimir putin
the war on ukraine have brought it to an
end i think that things have been
closing in on him for a few years now
and i think it's obviously come to a
head in the last week
european governments want to create a
hostile environment for putin's allies
and while abramovich denies political
influence just four days after planning
to pass the club to charity he's saying
goodbye for good
chelsea is the ultimate symbol of the
spending power of russia's oligarch
class but if roman abramovich is
scrambling to sell up here then other
lower profile alleged allies of vladimir
putin will be too and there are concerns
the british government is moving too
slowly to stop them moving their money
out of reach ministers are considering
emergency legislation to speed up
sanctions we have sanctioned
russian oligarchs and russian
organizations we've also gone further
than many others in banning vessels
russian vessels from our ports
enclosing airspace
to russian airplanes and we will
continue to sanction oligarchs as we
build the evidence case to do so
now added to the british list uzbek
billionaire alicia usmanov until this
week a sponsor of everton and a former
shareholder in arsenal he owns this
north london house valued at 48 million
pounds and a yacht on the left here that
the german authorities are considering
seizing
the uk has now sanctioned 13 individuals
since the invasion began a week ago
that's half the 26 targeted by eu action
and britain is accused of creating a
loophole for customers of russia's
second biggest bank vtb who have 30 days
to act before their assets have frozen
there are reports of a rush to sell
london property assets too as the net
tightens there is concern that the
delays
have permitted
some people who think they're going to
be sanctioned
to transfer money from bank accounts
they might have
in this jurisdiction elsewhere that
assumes of course they can find
somewhere and someone who will willingly
receive their funds
also added to the uk list former russian
deputy prime minister igor chuvalov said
to own apartments in this westminster
block no longer welcome so close to the
seat of power paul kelso sky news